for humans monitoring vital signs is
usually just a matter of wearing a small
device on the tip of your finger or a
quick listen with the stethoscope and
you're good to go
but for small animals such as mice or
birds checking vitals can involve
shaving hair plucking feathers sometimes
even surgery and anesthesia these
procedures can be stressful for the
animals and you don't always get the
best readings now researchers have
developed a non-invasive device that can
monitor the vital signs of small animals
using either tiny antennae or RFID tags
like those used in stores to track
inventory the device uses near-field
coherent sensing to read pulse heart
rate and breathing all without touching
the animal veer field refers to the
electromagnetic field directly around an
RFID antenna this allows readings up to
7 centimeters away from the antenna in
this setup the small antenna directs
waves of electromagnetic energy towards
the animal and towards a receiver once
these waves reflect off the body the
receiver can analyze the differences
between them changes in phase are used
to detect motion like breathing or pulse
the heartbeat is signaled by changes in
amplitude to get blood pressure the
timing of the heartbeat and pulse are
compared the researchers tested the
method on a rat and found the RFID
antenna was just as accurate and
monitoring heartbeat and breathing rate
as an electrocardiogram scientists
successfully tested the device parakeets
hamsters and beta fish-- yes even
underwater as touchless sensing
technology was originally developed for
reading vital science and humans imagine
a hospital before each patient has their
own unique RFID tag sewn directly into
their hospital gown with a central
reader that can monitor up to 200 people
at once the tags could even be used to
detect other internal motions in the
body such as bowel or eye movement
researchers believe in the future this
new technology will allow scientists to
track vital signs and a wide variety of
laboratory animals bets to check on
exotic pets much more humanely so your
hamster won't have to stress over
getting a haircut just to get a reading
of his heart rate
[Music]
you
[Music]